flash I've only been to Baltimore one
time I ate lunch there and the hostess
who like seats you at the restaurant had
a black
eye a full black it wasn't like what
happened it was pretty obvious what
happened we couldn't get over the fact
that we were like this is the face of
the company like this is this is who you
have greeting people and my boy who I
was with was like yeah I feel bad for
her man I feel like they should put her
in the kitchen or something where nobody
nobody has to see her face you know and
I was like yeah but I feel like if she
could cook she wouldn't have that black
[Applause]
eye I didn't find this joke particularly
funny or unique that's a matter of
opinion it was it was a get back in the
kitchen joke essentially but she can't
cuz she can't cook and she got a black
eye wait is some people didn't get that
there's always people who don't get the
joke gotta oh you say he laughed at a
woman for getting that's not the point
of joke but okay it did not go over well
on Tik Tok here's what one male feminine
had to say very eager to Signal his
support for women and how bad Matt re
was for daring to joke about such a
subject is this guy
gay cuz that jawline is making me gay
that is the craziest jawline you see
this
n what's wrong with it and like he's so
groomed that's okay man to be groomed
he's either going to church or he gay
you don't like to be
both
what what do that matter no just like
there's something about it was is that
as matters no it's observation mhm do
you think everything You observe or
you're trying to observe is m is
important no okay all right I just crazy
seeing cheekbones like this ain't this
like Superman esque this dude look like
he was draw handrawn pause I don't know
after the first like three minutes of
the mat R comedy special on Netflix and
turned it off because like dude bro you
betrayed your audience immediately you
told an unfunny joke about about
domestic violence against women stop
stop st he didn't betray his audience
his audience is female not feminist if
you go to see a show of a dude that is
funny and cute cuz let's be honest the
go the girl you girls go there cuz he's
funny and cute that's not very
feministic okay oh my God he's so cute
oh my that's not feminist okay so his
audience is not feminist it's woman in
that like some misogynic about them in
the kitchen cooking and pleasing their
man pleasing their husband and you you
betrayed them there was also kind of
like a woke Progressive identity
politics critique of this that Matt r as
a white man isn't allowed to speak on
these subjects take a listen Matt R
opened his comedy special with a
domestic violence joke right and it made
me realize that sometimes if you don't
have oppression of your own to pull from
you try to make fun of the oppression of
others but unfortunately you don't have
the angle of understanding to make it
funny right H the laughter because you
were supposed to picture a woman getting
hit because she can't cook and you were
supposed to laugh did you laugh is that
what he means by he made this for men
you want to make fun of domestic
violence yeah you know what it is for
mat I don't know him personally but I
imagine that when he just sees a bunch
of women coming to the show and yelling
you're hot he wants to be taken
seriously as a comedian so he wants to
make you clear like yo everyone's
welcome this is not a show where I just
look cute on stage for ladies and only
ladies find the jokes funny I want to
jokes at everyone's expense everyone
struggles and that's I think a good
thing I I think comedians always like
men are trash men are trash men are and
they also the other ones are like women
are horrible women are horrible it's
just kind of redundant if you were being
honest you know some ways in dudes be
[__] acting like [__] and you
know ways in which women be doing it you
should be laughing at everybody Muslims
Christians you know I hate people who
only make fun of one religion but the
two afraid make fun of the other
religion because the backlash that's
kind of cowardly in my opinion so shout
out to me he said everybody can get
these jokes and all of a sudden once the
audience who goes to watch them gets it
they want to lose their mind well not
all of them just some of them on Tik Tok
all your audience is females so you got
to root for them yeah yes yeah if
there's black people in my comedy show
I'mma laugh at them oh yeah but you're
shut the [__] up care but you're a black
person I don't care about that I don't
care yeah you going to make fun of
natives too y if natives come to your
show yep but they they don't have their
land yeah it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter everybody can get it everybody
can get it you're a guest on native land
and you want to make fun of them yep I
can I just want to take a moment out of
this video to take uh acknowledgement of
the fact that we are doing and shooting
this video on Stolen land and that's
really important to acknowledge cool
give it back huh give it back I don't
own it then shut the [__] up about that
[__] yeah I don't want it I hate I hate
people I hate this acknowledge yo I know
there's some I know there's some of my
native people out there is like yo they
love that [__] but I know there some
people that don't like it I hate when
they do it like light is started to do
that at every game of the Canadians of
Montreal we acknowledge that we are on
TJ L that mooh hotland that is unseated
give it back no give it back give the
same announcement give the same
announcement uh we just want to
acknowledge that this game it is on Chio
jaake a native land MOA land $5 for
cheesy tacos $5 right now two for one
special for H give it's like they give
this dumb [__] speech and then right
after go straight to the entertainment
like nothing happen hey I just want to
acknowledge a genocide happened here now
let's get these jokes means by he made
this for men you want to make fun of
domestic violence with men you want to
talk about your grandfather saying he
hooked up with Rosa Parks in the front
of the bus like all of these jokes are
dependent
on I'm sorry unintentionally this girl
said the most offensive thing she could
say and that [__] was
funny cuz it's so
absurd yeah the reason in the front of
the bus yeah that's yeah that's crazy so
you imag yo why did Rosa pck St to the
back of the bus I'm not getting in the
back cuz that dick is
delicious and that's the start of the
Civil Rights thing that's crazy know
what great about these people is like
underneath all the sjw [__] that
they do there's actually like a funny
person you just got to remove all them
[__] layers yeah talk about
something funny from your own life do
you have anything to pull from that is
interesting and Uniquely Yours and also
like funny like something F something
with a punchline like something with a
one to make me laugh I think we only do
this with comedy but it's like you go to
a restaurant you don't like the food you
don't like is this even food you just be
like oh I just don't like this kind of
Cuisine or I don't like this restaurant
you don't can you make something that
actually like is edible edible like can
you take like you use all those
spices from around the world don't you
have any spices on your
own yeah yeah you just didn't like the
food it's okay it happens the same way
you can go to a comedy show and not like
the jokes it happens you go to a show
you can love the comedian you may have
watched them 10 times and loved them
every time and you watch them one time
and it's trash cuz he's trying different
stuff out or today is just an off day
there was a Heckler in the audience that
threw off the temple it happens
whatever just because you didn't laugh
does not mean it's not funny just the
same way just because you didn't like
the food does not mean it's not food the
only disappointment that I'm
experiencing from this Matt rif situ Hey
listen I could already tell this girl
politics by that septum ring yep is the
disappointment knowing that there are
still women out there who were like
supporting him and thought that he was
funny and are now shocked that his
Netflix special came out and it's just
hot misogynistic garbage ladies you
really let that nasty ass fish lip
handsome Squidward face fool you you
actually she took time to write that one
um body shaming facts facts if they're
misogynistic it's okay to body shap
that's that's a lot of these L Body
shaming yep that's how that's how you
was able to see if you look like
Squidward with that anchor in your nose
Under the Sea cue that one clip of Matt
R from like more than a year ago on that
one podcast you know the one where he's
like horribly objectifying and talking
about women's bodies and women with big
clits and how he would never sleep with
a woman with a wow it's almost like Matt
R engages in the behavior his female
audience engages when they come to his
shows wow people objectify the upset sex
and they go wow she's hot cuz she's got
big titties wow wow people look at Matt
R and they say he's hot because pause
pause pause okay if you call someone
fish lips and Squidward uh you're doing
the same thing my girl it's just that is
not positive so check yourself before
you wreck yourself I I know most of
these ladies be buy these tickets to
Matt R and they be telling oh he's so
[__] hot look at his moon stop just
stop it stop Big Clip because it's like
she has a
penis that's so funny M and before
anyone hops on here and says it's comedy
anything goes yes potentially anything
goes if it's funny it's comedy you're
not the funny police you're not the one
that gets to the what is funny or not I
I don't think you're not I you know what
I think preach I don't think they don't
know that their way of saying it's not
funny is their ability to delegitimize
the opposite so that loses the
protection of it being a joke so they're
just doing that on purpose they know
damn well that comedy is subjective and
you're going to find some things funny
and some people won't it doesn't make it
any less no that's no that's not funny
yeah they just doing no that that is not
that is not funny yeah that's it for
these ones listen
I feel like every time these things end
up happening so this is a video from
Brad Palumbo who kind of put these
things together I'm not going to watch
some more Tik toks unless y'all really
want us to but yeah my thoughts on this
whole thing it's going to it's going to
two weeks and we're not talking about it
yeah yeah
M like oh my God you're just you know
what you're
doing all you people that try to cancel
them you're giving him more material for
a second special yep that's the only
thing you're doing
the second special he's going to talk
about all of y'all congratulations you
made him bag Hey listen good for Matt
you making all this money I I never met
live your life get some money let's go
Matt so let's know what you I've never
watched this comedy I've just seen like
Eclipse here and there on Tik Tok seen
but you know if it's good it's good if
people want to pay tickets they go pay
tickets what's funny what's not I'm
never going to be the police of that
everyone's going to have a different
opinion two weeks we're not talking
about that let us know what you guys
think in the comments below my guys such
yo
he's such a guy is getting paid do you
think he would lose a huge chunk of his
if he came out as gay I You' get more
you think he'd get more he'd get more I
think a lot of women would stop watching
cuz ladies love gay people and now it's
going to be the guys are going to be no
yes they do but they love dudes who are
accessible it's like Justin Timberlake
and those n sick dudes the reason why
none of them ever came out as gay is
because if they did they would lose a
fan base for it absolutely those women
are territorial about their let me ask
you when it comes to the women who are
like agila on dudes you don't think a
lot of them would be like oh he's not
even straight they'd be disappointed
women get mad women get mad some of them
get mad when you choose like women of a
specific race as your partner and they
want to stop watching because like
there's a bit of a weird thing like they
fantasize about to D yeah they don't
want to invented F fan fiction yeah I
think I think it would it's possible oh
who knows who knows I'm not saying he's
gay I'm he's gayish he's not how would
you know he not gayish did you watch him
[__] a
girl what how would you know you you
spent 2 minutes talking about a
motherfucker's jawline did you see him
[__] a girl knowing that he's gay I mean
the
reason yeah the reason mat got the same
so you so you watch people [__] F [__]
people I see people with that jawline
they l in the fu how how would you know
cuz I'm on
for I'm saying hey yo not CLI the video
hey yo you see thum
hey yo everyone
see
Yo nah nah don't do that that's
you this is
you